hello and welcome back to game review my
name is Caleb Denby and today I wanted
to do something a little bit different
instead of going over a professional
game or a classic game from from history
I wanted to go over an amateur game
specifically my amateur game I think
it's very instructive to see how the top
players play but also sometimes it's
more practical to see how an amateur
level plays amateur level player
approaches the game and how one player
ends up winning over another so in this
game I was playing a 2000 graded player
by the name of Griffin
Thomas McConnell and we played d4 Knight
f6 c4 e6 Knight c3 Bishop before
reaching a nimzo-indian defense I chose
the f3 variation which is my general
go-to we see d5 from black one of the
main options after a3 takes takes b6 C
takes d5 he takes d5 and III we reach a
position which is quite similar to a
game we've gone over earlier in this
series between Botvinnik and kappa
blanka and in that bond Finnick and
kappa blanka game black plays this move
Bishop a 6 well okay not right away
first castles Bishop d3 and then
something like Bishop a6 is a main way
of playing and approaching this opening
and the reason for that is a for a
reason I've said before in structures
like this where a c3 pawn is supporting
d4 the slight squared Bishop is a very
very powerful attacker of the Kings side
so very often black moment to trade off
this Bishop for the light square Bishop
of whites and that really holds true
here and this is really the only way to
kind of develop this this light squared
bishop for black there's no other good
square for it and we'll see that this is
a very serious mistake that my opponent
made in this game in the game you played
Queen e7 a move that doesn't really make
a ton of sense he is eyeing this epon
which could be described as weak but the
fact is it has plenty of defense with
this bishop on c1 so I continue
developing quite simply
now my opponent made the real mistake
which was Bishop b7 by committing this
bishop to the b7 square it might seem
like you're preventing e4 but the nature
of the position is such that white can
always get efore in eventually you know
you can bring enough pieces over to the
center to support this efore break and
it's just it's going to come through no
matter what so it's much much better to
trade this bishop off for this bishop
rather then bring it to b7 of course you
do have to Castle first everybody should
know this tactic Bishop a6 I'll let you
try and find the win for white of course
Bishop takes a 696 with with a fork so
that's one to avoid but black could
simply Castle here and then follow that
up with Bishop a6 instead though Queen B
792 Knight bd7
and already this is kind of mistake
number two for for black of course in
this opening as I've mentioned before
blacks play is going to come on the
Queen side with moves like especially c5
and knight c6 and an eventual expansion
of probably a six and B 5 and B 4 this
is how black wants to find counter play
and instead black brings this night to
be sore from b8 2 to d7
there's just no future for this night
there's no home that it can reach from
the d7 square it's not really
contributing to this to the play in the
center and this is the first topic I
wanted to talk about with this game in a
lot of amateur level games you know
you're told
develop your pieces castle your King and
you can't go wrong in the opening when
you are unfamiliar with the opening you
should rely on these principles to kind
of guide you through the complications
and well that holds true once you reach
a certain point it's not enough and so I
wanted to add the rule to develop your
pieces I wanted to add to it with a
purpose you need to develop your pieces
with a purpose you can click on d7 is a
developed piece it's off the back rank
but the fact is a piece is only really
developed if it's contributing to the
game that's the point in developing your
pieces you want them to contribute
to be a part of the action and from d7
this night simply does not do that
so that was black's big mistake in this
game is developing his pieces but
developing them so haphazardly that they
don't really serve a good purpose and
that makes all the difference in this
position that being said when your
opponent does something strange you
don't always need to punish it
immediately
I simply Castle black simply castles as
well and I let the position kind of
speak for itself you don't need to try
really really hard to review to refute
play like this you just need to follow
your plan and improve your position so
my plan is to play E for I play Knight
g3 supporting this break this Rick comes
to e8 I play rook a to this is kind of a
common maneuver nicknamed the Machuca
rook here at the st. Louis chess club
where you lift the rook up one Square
and then bring it over to to the action
on the other side of the board now my
opponent tries to justify putting this
night on d7 by bringing it to f8 where
it can see some of these squares but
really from these squares it also isn't
doing enough in the game i bring this
Rick to the center to support this efore
break black plays c5 trying to slow down
efore by pressuring d4 but black has
simply wasted too much time by moving
this Knight all the way to FA moving
this trick to e8 and so the fact is I
can play my plan without too much
difficulty here and at this point why it
is simply completely winning it's more
than +3 already and which might be
surprising to you but this is not the
type of opening where you can waste your
time moving your pieces back and forth
and because of that this game very very
quickly got out of blacks hands we see
pawn takes d4 pawn takes d4 pawn takes
e4 pawn takes e4 and after Queen d7 it's
really really tough to find a move for
black Queen d7 looks a little bit
strange it does make a threat but like I
said I mean it's very difficult to find
a playable move for black so of course
my pawns attacked I simply defend it
there's no rush in White's position here
all of my threats
are going to be permanent and there's no
good way to solve these problems for
black in the game my opponent shows
Knight g6 and here I'll allow you you
viewers at home to try and find the
absolute crushing move for white here
there's a move that just puts black away
immediately and and pretty much ends
ends the game okay hopefully you found
it
the move is of course the wonderful
sacrifice rook takes f6 this is the key
move here it rips open blacks Kings side
and after a black would recapture you
have this move Knight h5 eyeing this f6
pawn threatening to fork no fewer than
three pieces if black wants to try to
defend we can now play d5 unveiling this
Bishop from b2 and really really putting
black out of the game here you have a
couple options of course you could
capture this if you wanted black would
be forced to take to save the queen
but I think more powerful is simply
Queen d2 with the idea of of coming into
checkmate coming in to checkmate black
so rook takes f6 is a very nice move
that would have ended the game on the
spot in the game I was feeling a bit
lazy I didn't want to calculate rook
takes f6
so I played Queen d2 hoping for an
improved version where I could bring the
Queen to h6 immediately following her it
takes f6 seeing this coming black
probably should have tried to move like
Knight g4 to try and keep the short
takes f6 from from not occurring but at
the end of the day it's it's not going
to be enough I move like h3 will make
this Knight move again and now after
Bishop c1 this this night is really
trapped and this this structure is going
to become fractured anyways so in the
game though my opponent played rook a d8
a fairly nonchalant move when in fact
now rook takes f6 is game ending I
continued with Queen h6 and now one
final test for you at home if Queen g4
what is the move for white only
move winds okay is it tonight f5
no it is not night f5 well this is good
for white it's only about +1 blacks
threat is to play Knight f4 when he can
defend this quite adequately so we have
to do better in the night f5 we have to
make a second threat and that is exactly
what Knight h5 does threatens Knight
takes f6 winning a Queen and Queen g7
winning the King you might be thinking
well what if black tries to sidestep
both threats with the move King h8 will
star not King h8 wait a second
okay so if King h8 here still Knight h5
is the one I was thinking of now for a
g8 to try to stop it
Knight f6 once again wins the game and
so as well in this Knight h5 line
there's simply no way to stop both of
these threats in the game my opponent
tried Knight f4 throws away at night for
a tempo I take it he plays Queen back to
e7 and now I just bring this Knight the
f5 and this is where my opponent decided
to throw in the towel so this was a
pretty simple game actually there was
that key tactic with rook takes f6 the
take away to keep in mind from this game
is that you don't want to develop
without a purpose because you can very
quickly find yourself in a position
where pieces are uncoordinated and none
of them are really contributing to the
game so always develop with a purpose
with that in mind thank you once again
for joining me for today's game review
my name is Caleb Denby and I will see
you in the next episode